non, cette église est exactement au centre de
la ville, il avait ce truc avec des points rouges
pour les yeux et donc nous répétions en le
regardant pour qu'il puisse avoir
quelque chose à répondre, puis pendant
une prise, nous devions aimer regarder trois pieds
au-dessus de sa tête, ce qui était tellement irritant
parce qu'il faisait tellement de choses que vous
vouliez probablement regarder la majorité des
tirs dans les airs et je vais tous les deux comme ça
comme un tournage, nous ne voulions pas qu'un
Ultron flotte juste là-bas tout
seul nous voulions  qu'il ait fait équipe avec
quelqu'un que nous voulions qu'il y ait une
opportunité pour que les jumeaux aident à porter une
partie de ce fardeau de méchant, ces
personnages font partie intégrante des
bandes dessinées Avengers, nous voulions également avoir
un autre personnage féminin puissant que je
ne voulais pas comme une nouvelle perspective mais  un
nouveau langage visuel qu'elle peut entrer dans
leur tête il peut bouger pour que
tout soit super lent ça va
me donner un langage que je n'aurais pas utilisé
pour le premier que j'ai acheté Naruto
vision est drôle bro messages edal  un
concept pair AMA
un bruit quelle est l'activité réelle VD
où Adam impair